mais monsieur le président ravi de six
ministres
chers collègues sénat pour la
traditionnelle la séance de questions
cribles thématiques consacrées cet
après-midi un sujet particulièrement
d'actualité puisqu'il s'agit de la
réforme de la pac et que l' enveloppe
consacrée dans le budget européen pour
2014 2020 a encore été jugée
insuffisante
hier par le ministre de l'agriculture
stéphane le foll à plusieurs reprises
lors d'une réunion avec ses homologues à
bruxelles le ministre français a dit
qu'il fallait progresser les aides
directes et l' enveloppe consacrée au
développement rural ont été amputés de
8,3 milliards d'euros des coupes
inacceptable selon paris car je vous
rappelle et bien que la france est le
premier pays bénéficiaire de la pac et
la politique agricole commune tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle pour
cette séance de questions cribles où
vous l'avez compris les sénateurs auront
bien des questions à poser à stéphane le
foll bonne science à tous deux primés
les premiers hectares ce qui reviendrait
pour la france à doubler quasiment la
prime aux exploitations allant jusqu'à
50 ha semble aller dans le bon sens et
pourrait permettre de prendre davantage
en compte un certain nombre de critères
sociaux et environnementaux dans la
répartition de ces aides
cependant on a pu le constater le
plafonnement ainsi que la dégressivité
des aides a toujours été rejetée par le
conseil des ministres de l'agriculture
lorsque la commission le proposer et ce
depuis le début des années 90
actuellement il semblerait que le
royaume uni l'allemagne la république
tchèque et la slovaquie
soit les pays qui s'y opposent le plus
ma question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre quels sont à l'heure actuelle
où en sont à l'heure actuelle les
négociations et pouvez-vous nous assurer
que vous pourrez trouver une majorité
qualifiée tout sur votre proposition
première partie de la question et la
seconde
votre proposition n'est pas
officiellement encore chiffré pouvez
vous nous communiquez des simulations
plus clair sur cette proposition
pour que les agriculteurs en france
puissent anticiper
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt je le
président le sénateur
vous avez évoqué d'abord la question des
négociations à l'échelle européenne sur
la politique agricole je voudrais vous
rappeler qu'elles ne sont pas dissociés
des négociations globales sur le budget
et que la position de la france et du
président de la république a été de
défendre l'idée que en europe
aujourd'hui deux grandes politiques qui
recoupe à peu près 80 % de ce budget
sont concernés par la politique agricole
et la politique de cohésion est que pour
arriver à faire porter un message de la
france à l'échelle européenne en
particulier sur l'agriculture ne fallait
pas oublier cette politique de cohésion
ça a été la stratégie et je pense que la
france a été de ce fait autour de cette
position du président de la république
au coeur des négociations
c'est le premier point et vous savez que
le débat sur le budget s'est posé avec
des propositions qui avaient été faites
d'abord par une présidence chypriote il
ya à peu près deux mois et ensuite par
la présidence de monsieur vendront moy
sur une base budgétaire de l'ordre de 9
163 milliards dont on est remonté
aujourd'hui à 983 milliards d'euros dans
ce cadre la france défend l'idée de la
politique agricole pas simplement pour
dire c'est un besoin pour notre pays
bien entendu que c'est un enjeu
important pour notre pays
mais c'est aussi nous le pensons un
enjeu majeur pour l'europe toute entière
agriculture alimentation dans le monde
de demain
c'est un enjeu stratégique la france a
une position particulière dans ce débat
mais elle porte au travers de cette
position pour notre pays
une ambition aussi pour l'europe c'est
pourquoi là dessus nous avons été
extrêmement clair par rapport aux
propositions qui avaient été faites par
monsieur vendre on paye sur ensuite la
politique agricole en tant que tel
s'engagerait au moment où les
perspectives financières seront adoptées
dans le cadre du conseil européen la
réforme de la politique agricole elle
même et vous l'avez évoqué avec des
discussions qui portent sur trois grands
sujets majeurs
le premier c'est ce qu'on appelle une
convergence à la fois européenne
et nationale sur la base des taux à
l'hectare les mêmes pour tous des coupes
les sujets essentiels coeur du débat
aujourd'hui à l'échelle européenne sur
laquelle la france par ma voix a fait la
proposition de pouvoir primer de manière
supplémentaire
les premiers hectares une note est prête
elle sera envoyée à l'ensemble des
ministres du conseil européen et au
député européen du parlement et vous en
serez vous-même saisie qui fixera la
ligne du positionnement de la france sur
cette question qui nous paraît
importante
deuxièmement il ya la question du
verdissement la france est un grand pays
qui aujourd'hui pèse pour que la
question de l'environnement soit posée à
l'échelle européenne pour garder la
cohérence dans l'ensemble des pays
d'europe sur une politique
environnementale qu'il peut pas laisser
chaque pays faire des choix différents
les uns des autres
si on veut avoir une agriculture durable
c'est à l'échelle de l'europe toute
entière
voilà sur ces points là et je termine
par la question du plafonnement
vous l'avez évoqué sur cette question
évidemment il ya des oppositions
extrêmement forte et claire de
l'allemagne de la grande bretagne de
l'espagne
l'aca 32 pays merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur l'abbé merci monsieur le
ministre de la clarté relative de votre
de votre réponse
en comprenant que vous ne puissiez pas
aller plus loin pour le moment
maintenant au sujet du plafonnement s'il
y a déjà quelques quelques réticences
nous irions nous jusqu'à proposer
au-delà des 300 mille euros de
plafonnement jusqu'à jusqu'à plafonner
le versement des aides directes à 100000
euros
cette mesure permettrait dans l'europe à
27 de récupérer entre 5,6 et demi
milliard d'euros par an sur 40 millions
et donc en france plus de 50 850
millions cette marge de manoeuvre nous
permettrait de redistribuer les soutiens
publics de manière plus équitable entre
les états membres et entre les
agriculteurs tout en facilitant
l'émergence de pratiques agricoles moins
polluantes et en soutenant l'emploi dans
l'ensemble des zones rurales
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur gilbert barbier pour le goût
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le dernier sommet
européen s'est soldée par un échec des
négociations sur les crédits de la pac
je vous écoute de suite dire que la
ligne défendue par la france a été
entendue
les 8 milliards supplémentaires mais sur
la table vendredi constitue certes un
petit progrès par rapport à la
proposition initiale mais on est loin du
compte
je rappelle que le budget de la pac qui
était de 421 milliards sur la période
précédente
vous appelez à ne pas dramatiser cet
échec sans doute vaut-il mieux qu'un
mauvais accord
mais en attendant les agriculteurs ne
savent pas toujours de quoi leur avenir
sera fait les éleveurs en particulier
sont très inquiet secteur laitier est
appelé une grande mutation avec la
suppression des quotas en 2015
il est aujourd'hui loin de vivre
dignement de son travail
ce secteur est celui des bovins viande
apparaissent comme les plus fragilisées
par le projet de réforme de la pac
d'abord la convergence des paiements
directs entre agriculteurs leur est
défavorable
vous avez émis l'idée de doubler la
prime aux 50 premiers hectares c'est de
progresser cette proposition
progresse-t-elle auprès de vos collègues
européens
les éleveurs laitiers quant à eux
avancent l'idée d'une aide dédié à la
vache laitière certaine elle sert
certaines elles seront elles couple et
demain comme la prime à la vache
allaitante
sans cette incitation le cheptel
allaitant pourrait être fortement
réduits des craintes élèves aussi quant
au verdissement de la pac
le gel de 7% des surfaces serait une
catastrophe pour les petites
exploitations
disposant de faible surface pour
l'alimentation animale
est il prévu des exonérations enfin la
discussion autour du 2e pilier et pour
les éleveurs en particulier se situe en
zone de montagne capitale monsieur le
ministre l'élevage c'est la richesse de
nos territoires ruraux
le maintien de cette activité suppose
des mesures spécifiques dans la pac à
venir notamment pour réguler les marchés
que pouvez vous dire aujourd'hui des
négociations qui pourraient rassurer les
éleveurs lesquels le voit par ailleurs
les crédits du plan de modernisation des
bâtiments d'élevage fondre en 2013 dans
le budget national
merci monsieur barbier
le ministre et sénateur d'abord je peux
pas vous laisser dire que la question de
l'échec des négociations est un élément
de dramatisation
si vous vous rappelez des discussions
sur les perspectives financières
précédentes
elles ont duré plus de un an elles ont
vu des crises bien plus importantes que
celles que nous avons connues même s'ils
n'y a pas eu de compromis donc
n'intégrait pas vous même l'idée qu'à la
première réunion européenne sur les
perspectives financières
il y allait avoir un accord sinon bien
sûr vous allez le dire c'est un échec
oui c'est un échec mais pensez quand
même qu'on parle de 7 ans de
perspectives financières pour toute
l'europe et que ça va prendre un peu de
temps
faut pas se tromper ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point sur la question
financière
on a remonté d'unir c'est peut-être et
je les dis déjà un progrès c'est
insuffisant on continuera bien entendu
on va pas s'arrêter là
sur les points liés à l'élevage vous
faites une erreur
monsieur le sénateur la convergence des
aides proposées aujourd'hui au niveau du
premier pilier a plutôt comme objectif
de favoriser les zones d'élevage et
d'herbage en particulier par définition
puisque ça fait partie du paquet du
verdissement et deuxièmement cette
convergence qui rasent qui consiste à
ramener l'ensemble des aides autour d'un
taux moyen pour toute la france fait que
ceux qui sont en dessous du taux moyen
aujourd'hui vers et leur z augmente et
donc ne dit pas ça non plus
à partir de là qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est là que l'enjeu est important
dans l'élevage c'est que c'est pas
simplement la question de l'élevage
allaitant qu'est posée c'est l'ensemble
de l'élevage et surtout de la
polyculture élevage qui est posée est là
par contre il ya des risques et les
risques importants
d'où les propositions que j'ai faites à
la fois sur les premiers hectares pour
protéger cette polyculture élevage tenir
compte en particulier de l'emploi parce
que c'est un enjeu majeur et maintenir
et ça c'est une n'annonce qu'il faut que
chacun en mesure bien la porte et
maintenir les aides couplées
il est hors de question et ça ça a été
dit
et je le répète de changer quoi que ce
soit sur le couplage des aides
donc je réponds là à des questions
précises je terminerai sur le
plafonnement ne vous trompez pas non
plus c'est pas parce qu on plafonne
qu'on fait du verdissement
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
lazhar oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je peux également de témoigner comme l'a
fait mon collègue gilbert barbier de
l'inquiétude des agriculteurs en général
et en particulier de ceux dont
l'activité principale est vis levage qui
plus est en zone de montagne comme dans
mon département l'aveyron nous sommes
toutefois convaincu des intentions
affichées par le chef de l'état et le
gouvernement qui dans la négociation du
budget de l'union européenne ont
clairement prioriser la défense de la
pac
il est vrai que c'est une réduction des
dépenses s'impose aussi au niveau
européen
les agriculteurs français ne doit pas
être la variable d'ajustement de la
négociations budgétaires entre les 27
votre réponse à mon collègue gilbert
barbier du ministre s'inscrit dans le
droit fil de cette ambition affichée par
le gouvernement en faveur de nos
territoires
nos territoires de montagne et de ses
acteurs un dispensaire des agriculteurs
au titre des orientations de cette
nouvelle pac
je souligne la possibilité qui serait
donnée aux états membres d'élaborer des
sous programmes bénéficiant de taux dead
supérieur afin de répondre aux besoins
qui se nouent sont cruciaux des jeunes
agriculteurs et de leurs installations
des petits exploitants des zones de
montagne et des circuits
d'approvisionnement cours il la parole
est à monsieur jean bizet pour le groupe
ump
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
revenir sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel qui fait l'objet d'un débat
à bruxelles pour souligner je le dis
très clairement la maladresse à mon avis
dans les négociations de la france tout
simplement parce que la france je dirais
cherche à obtenir à la fois le maintien
des crédits la politique agricole
commune des fonds de cohésion des fonds
compétitivité et tout cela dans le cadre
d'une modération budgétaire
j'avoue que quand on chasse entre
guillemets si vous me permettez
l'expression quatre lièvres à la fois
j'ai peur malheureusement que vous non
à pied aucun et si on analyse est à peu
près exact logiquement la baisse des
crédits pas qu'aujourd'hui se chiffre à
environ 22 25 milliards d'euros
première question quelle est la somme en
deçà de laquelle vous considérez que
c'est un chiffon rouge et vous
comprennent la négociation puisque ces
négociations doivent se dérouler à
l'unanimité deuxième point que je
voudrais aborder concerne la filière
laitière
la france a été initiative initiatrice
pendant du paquet lait qui a prévu la
contractualisation et le regroupement
des producteurs
le commissaire ciolos rappelait
d'ailleurs récemment l' influence de la
france sur ce sujet mais immédiatement
après il s'étonnait de voir kylie a très
peu de progrès en particulier en france
sur ce sujet je comprends la révolte des
producteurs laitiers dont la presse a
rendu compte dernièrement mais ceux qui
réclament des prix administrés se
trompent
l'europe ne reviendra pas sur les quotas
laitiers et sur les prix de référence
peut parfois le regretter mais c'est
ainsi
il faut donc chercher d'autres remèdes
d'autres pistes notamment celle de
rééquilibrer les relations entre les
producteurs éleveurs et les industriels
distributeurs
je considère que l'avenir de la filière
laitière se joue en ce moment
que comptez vous faire pour favoriser le
regroupement des producteurs sur
ministre que compte faire le
gouvernement pour s'impliquer davantage
dans ce dossier et ne pas laisser la
main à l'autorité de la concurrence
toujours je dirais très crispée sur ces
questions alors que quand on vois de
l'autre côté du rhin d'autres pays avoir
réglé déjà le problème sur le les
relations avec l'autorité de concurrence
merci si monsieur visait monsieur le
ministre monsieur sénateurs d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que la stratégie
précédente qui consistait à proposer à
l'europe que la france baisse sa
contribution au budget de 200 milliards
tout en défendant le maintien du budget
de la politique agricole commune était
là pour le coup je maladroite mais en
tout cas nous amener directement dans
une position totalement isolé qui aurait
fait payer deux fois tout le monde
et la position que nous avons prises
c'est d'éviter les prisonniers si vous
ne comprenez pas qu'à l'échelle de
l'europe lés pays de la cohésion toute
l'europe centrale qui sont prêts à
défendre la politique agricole
mais si vous leur dites on ne fait que
la politique agricole non vous abandonne
complètement sur la politique de
cohésion
vous n'avez plus aucun soutien et je
vous rappelle que la grande bretagne les
pays bas le danemark la suède et
l'allemagne ne sont pas ceux qui seront
les premiers à monter pour défendre la
politique agricole commune
donc votre stratégie précédente je vous
le dis de manière sincère et claire
était celle qui nous conduisait à
l'échec
la stratégie que nous avons conduite est
au contraire serre qui nous met au coeur
du débat et qui nous permet d'avoir des
alliances avec beaucoup d'autres pays
la ligne franco espagnole a été une
solidité d'une solidité majeur
l'italie a suivi et nous avons pu avec
la pologne réaliser un équilibre général
au niveau budgétaire
c'est la bonne stratégie et je vous le
dis j'en suis totalement convaincu pour
avoir été moi même vice président du
parlement européen
je sais ce qu'il fallait sur ce sujet
faire et surtout ce qu'il ne fallait pas
faire c'est ce que vous aviez commencé à
faire avant que nous arrivions au mois
de mai deuxième point sur la question
laitière la contractualisation oui il ya
un paquet lait une crise laitiers en
2008 a été majeur sachez monsieur le
sénateur que cette question de la
contractualisation ne règle en rien la
question posée sur la question des tiers
il ya deux éléments
1 qu'est ce qui se passe après les
quotas laitiers et là la france va
prendre des initiatives et deux sur la
contractualisation celle qui a été
décidé par là et les mas devra être
évoluer changer parce que ce que vous
avez mis en oeuvre n'est pas suffisant
en particulier pour tenir compte des
indicateurs de prix qui nécessite qu'un
contrat permettre aux agriculteurs
d'avoir une visibilité plus grande que
celle que l'union aujourd'hui c'est tout
l'enjeu des groupes qui ont été mis en
place au niveau d'agrimer et qui
rendront leurs conclusions à la fin de
l'année et à partir de là nous
changerons pour organiser les
producteurs et faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent peser sur les choix en termes
de quantité et surtout de prix merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur bizet
monsieur le ministre vous me permettrez
de ne pas partager la première partie de
votre analyse vous le comprendrez bien
et que vous avez clairement dit
également qu'il y avait un axe fort la
france avec l'espagne où je considère
que pourquoi pas certes mais ceci à mon
avis a été fait au détriment d'un axe à
mon avis beaucoup plus fort quand on
veut faire avancer l'europe qui est lax
et le couple franco allemand
on verra bien comment se termineront le
je dirais les négociations puisque ça
doit se faire à l'unanimité je suis tout
à fait d'accord qu'il faut je dirais
fédérer un certain nombre d'alliances
c'est ce qu'avait fait votre
prédécesseur brawn monsieur bruno le
maire s'est pas du tout ce que j'ai cru
sentir après que vous ayez pris la
direction de ce ministère mais nous
verrons bien donnons nous rendez vous
dans quelques mois
tant qu'à la contractualisation il est
bien évident que ce n'est qu'un début
que l'utilisation des indicateurs de
tendance est fondamental dans la
vitalité dans la pérennité des contrats
qui doivent lier les agriculteurs et les
entreprises
donc là aussi moi j'attends les
résultats
je souhaiterais que des messages très
important souhaite adresser précisément
la profession agricole qui a besoin
d'être je dirais soutenus pour pouvoir
précisément se regrouper parce que c'est
la seule solution pour pouvoir peser
dans la détermination des je dirais de
la valeur ajoutée de la filière
merci la parole est à monsieur gérard
roche pour le groupe
udi us et nice très chers collègues
comme de nombreux collègues députés
sénateurs comme de nombreux agriculteurs
français et comme rouge je sais monsieur
le ministre je suis préoccupé par les
négociations européennes sur le budget
de la politique agricole commune
les coupes proposées par président de
l'union européenne sont inadmissibles
elles font notamment chuté de 4,7 pour
cent le financement du premier pilier de
la pac est presque à de 4,9 pour ça le
montant consacré aux paiements des aides
directes
je salue monsieur le ministre votre
volonté d'imiter la diminution du budget
consacré à la pac
cet engagement de la france pour son
agriculture est nécessaire vous devez
être ferme et constant je sais que vous
serez comme ont été vos prédécesseurs
qu'il faut remercier leurs actions
néanmoins je suis particulièrement
inquiet concernant le niveau et le
modèle de redistribution de soutien
direct la convergence prévue à partir de
2015 serait une forme d'uniformisation
par le bas de ces aides
elle pourrait donc entraîner une baisse
de soutien à l'hectare pour nos
agriculteurs et alors pénaliser les plus
fragiles d'entre elles propos mes chers
collègues je voudrais vous rappeler ici
profiter cette tribune pour dire que
lorsqu'un producteur de lait de mon
département la haute loire vient à paris
il doit vendre 10 lits de l'est pour
quoi se payer un café dans un bar des
champs elysées on ne peut pas infliger
cela à ces gens à imaginer que le dput
le droit au paiement unique par hectare
ne s'élève qu'à 250 euros j'aimerais
vous proposez que ceux des pays soit au
contraire augmenté pour les 50 premiers
hectares ha et qu'en contrepartie sera
diminuée au delà 300 hectares cela
permettrait d'équilibrer la demande de
la france vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne et de se tenir simultanément
nous agriculteurs
je sais que certaines le collègue député
vous ont déjà suggéré cela et que vous y
êtes vous même plutôt favorable je crois
malheureusement que le partenaire
européen et notamment l'allemagne sont
hostiles
monsieur le ministre quel est votre
opinion sur ce sur ce sujet où en sont
les négociations et cette proposition
peut-elle fructifier merci monsieur le
ministre mais son président le sénateur
vous m'avez donc interrogé à la fois de
manière globale sur l'inquiétude que
vous exprimer sur l'évolution des aides
et surtout sur cette fameuse convergence
des aides
elle est effectivement un enjeu et toute
la bataille que nous conduisons pour moi
en tout cas depuis le départ c'est de
considérer que l'idée d'un découplage
total des aides avec un taux unique à
l'hectare partout en europe
c'est un risque je vous le dis majeur de
spécialisation de l'agriculture dans les
grandes zones européennes
et la france deviendrait la grande zone
de production céréalière le grenier à
blé de l'europe mais perdrait ce qui
fait à la fois l'emploi et la valeur
ajoutée c'est la transformation des
céréales en particulier dans la viande
bovine dans la viande porcine dans le
lait dans toutes les productions
d'élevage
tout l'enjeu pour nous c'est de faire
prendre en compte cette dimension là et
en particulier aussi d'étendre au
travers du couplage des aides les
éléments que vous évoquez sur
l'agriculture de montagne où le
pastoralisme à un rôle tout ça sera pris
en compte et les indemnités de
compensation du handicap
aussi nous ne lâcherons pas là dessus et
la prime à la vache allaitante bien
entendu ensuite sur la question des
premiers hectares et la question du
plafonnement
le vrai problème à l'échelle européenne
c'est que il est très difficile de faire
des transferts aujourd'hui il ya eu un
moment qui a été celui de la modulation
des aides qu'à utiliser michel barnier
pour faire un transfert d'une partie des
céréales vers les productions
fourragères et ben hebert bajer et
l'élevage
ce qu'on va faire avec la prime des
premiers hectares c'est en partie faire
aussi ce type de transfert pour éviter
surtout que la perte de dpu d'une partie
des exploitations en polyculture élevage
soit pour elle la remise en cause de la
viabilité économique de ces
exploitations et en même temps d'assurer
cette nouvelle répartition des aides à
l'échelle de notre pays c'est ça l'enjeu
de tous les débats
alors le vrai problème sur le
plafonnement je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est qu'il ya des pays qui sont opposés
à cela et de manière très claire
donc je suis favorable à cette idée du
plafonnement mais je n'ai pas construit
la proposition de la france uniquement
sur ce sujet parce qu'au bout du compte
je sais que j'aurai des oppositions
extrêmement fortes sur cette question
par un certain nombre de pays qui le
justifie pour ce qui est de l'allemagne
par exemple parce que dans les anciens
länder de l'est
vous avez des exploitations issus du
modèle communiste qui font 1000 1500
hectares sur lesquels ils ont mis en
place des coopérateurs agricoles et donc
qu'ils considèrent que le plafonnement
de ces aides à l'état ça serait la
remise en cause d'un emploi dans ces
länder et ils ne l'accepteront jamais et
ça ça a été la position qui a été
réitéré par l'allemagne donc on est
obligé de concevoir non pas uniquement
l'idée du plafonnement mais surtout de
la dégressivité des aides c'est tout
l'enjeu de ces premiers hectares arrivé
à montrer qu'il peut y avoir une
dégressivité des êtres et surtout au
fond derrière tout ça a montré que
l'idée qu' on n'est pas pour aller tout
de suite vers un taux unique à l'hectare
qui risquerait s'il était en plus
totalement découplé de voir les grandes
zones européennes de production agricole
se spécialiser en fonction de leurs
avantages comparatifs sanou
voulons pas et monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur joël guerriau oui
monsieur le ministre nous avons entendu
votre réponse s'il ya un point sur
lequel la france est mal à l'aise c'est
bien celui de la convergence des niveaux
dead et je me souviens de vous avoir
entendu sur une chaîne de radio le
journaliste vous interrogeait sur le
grand écart des niveaux des d'entre eux
filière en particulier entre éleveurs et
céréaliers et vous aviez habilement
éludé la question répondant sur la
convergence externes c'est-à-dire sur
les écarts de niveaux dead entre états
membres
mais le dossier le plus épineux et bien
évidemment la convergence interne une
première étape avait été franchie vous
l'a rappelé en 2008 lors du bilan de
santé de la pac et on se souvient des
difficultés de monsieur barnier pour
faire accepter une modeste
redistribution des aides des céréaliers
en direction des éleveurs
mais ce premier pas n'est rien par
rapport à l'objectif dato unique par
hectare même régionalisés nous
comprenons monsieur le ministre
l'embarras que vous pouvez prouver à
évoquer ce sujet car l'application de la
mesure sera évidemment très difficile
tant elle implique des redistribution
entre secteurs voire entre exploitations
la proposition française que vous avez
rappelé de valoriser les aides aux 50
premiers hectares semble avoir la faveur
du président ciolos
elle vous fait des estimations sur les
conséquences que cela va entraîner dans
la distribution de ces aides
ce sera vrai simplement la vraie sable
va vraisemblablement excusez moi l'un
des difficultés majeures de
l'application de la réforme de la pac à
la france j'espère que le gouvernement
sera à la hauteur de ce rendez vous
merci de votre écoute
si mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame bernadette bourzai pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues ma question portera sur
deux points 1 qui a déjà été largement
abordé l'état d'avancement des
négociations sur le futur de la pac et
le second sur la répartition des aides
dans notre pays dans monsieur bériault
viens de parler la convergence interne
la réforme de la pac était le point
principal de l'ordre du jour du conseil
dont vous revenez monsieur le ministre
et je ne doute pas que le dernier sommet
européen des 22 et 23 novembre à un peu
impacté vos travaux puisqu'il n'ya pour
le moment pas d'accord sur le cadre
financier pluriannuel pour la période
2014 2020
mais comment pourrions-nous déterminer
une politique agricole ambitieuse sans
en connaître les financements c'est
pourquoi nous soutenons les efforts et
la détermination du président de la
république qui défend fermement un
budget européen ambitieux pour maintenir
des montants suffisant pour la pac et
qui permettent aussi de relever les
défis de la cohésion du soutien à la
croissance et à l'emploi en europe
comme vous avez déjà largement répandu
sur la question de l'état des
négociations sur le montant de la pac je
précise enfin je souhaiterais avoir des
précisions sur la répartition des fonds
agricoles entre le 1er et le 2e pilier
c'est à dire les aides directes et le
développement de rural dont la
négociation précédente 2007 2013 avait
taillé de 35% les montants ce qui à mon
avis est une mauvaise chose en matière
de développement rural d'innovation de
recherche et de capacités effectivement
de valorisation sur place ma deuxième
question porte sur l'impact national de
la réforme de la pac
vous pouvez compter sur notre soutien
dans vos efforts pour intégrer de
nouveaux objectifs sur l'emploi la
préservation de l'environnement et une
répartition plus équitable des aides en
préservant d'abord les filières qui en
ont le plus besoin
vous le savez tous les systèmes de
production ne sont pas dans la même
situation certains sont fortement
employeurs de main-d'oeuvre d'autres
beaucoup moins
certains sont intactes impactée par la
volatilité des prix je pense aux
éleveurs et d'autres en sont
bénéficiaires
la diversité de notre agriculture
constitue une richesse elle est aussi
une source d'inégalité qu'il convient de
réduire pour légitimer la pac
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre je
vous pose la question de comment
maintenir et développer l'emploi en
milieu rural favoriser le
système de polyculture-élevage éviter
une trop forte orientation vers les
cultures céréalières maintenir les
petites et moyennes exploitations qui
sont encore les garante du maintien de
l'agriculture dans nos territoires
merci madame monsieur le ministre je le
brillant madame la sénatrice chère
bernadette bourzai sur les plus jeunes
il ya plusieurs questions dans ce que
vous avez évoqué la première c'est le
rapport 1er 2e pilier bon c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les aides à la production
sur le premier pilier dans la
négociation sont un objectif qui est
important globalement pour l'équilibré
général et l'ars et distribution et des
objectifs ou de succès la bataille va se
porter sur le 2e pilier et là il ya
effectivement comme à chaque fois des
tentations abc ce deuxième pilier qui
fait l'objet d'ailleurs des de la
mobilisation qui sera la nôtre dans les
semaines qui viennent aussi parce que
nous avons besoin de supplier pour
accompagner les politiques du premier
pilier deuxième point par rapport à ce
que vous dites la question se pose avec
plusieurs outils
le premier c'est ce que je viens
d'évoquer ce dont on discute aujourd'hui
c'est les primes aux premiers hectares
puisque c'est dans les exploitations
autour de la moyenne en termes
d'hectares que se trouve le plus
d'emplois c'est dans l'élevage et la
polyculture élevage qu'on a le plus
d'emplois et donc si on cible ces
exploitations
on a en même temps la capacité de tenir
compte de la question de l'emploi c'est
bien ça l'enjeu
deuxième point on a à partir de là a
ajouté à ses objectifs
la question du couplage des aides je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure toute la
compensation du handicap
si on compense pas les handicaps vous
avez tout un tas d'exploitation qui
aujourd'hui ne pourrait plus assurer
leur viabilité économique deuxième
élément majeur c'est pour l'élevage le
maintien d'un couplage sur les vaches
allaitantes bien entendu parce que ça
c'est un enjeu tout ça se combinent pour
aller dans le sens que vous évoquez et
pour faire en sorte que cette réforme de
la politique agricole permettent
d'assurer et une redistribution et de
focaliser sur les points essentiels qui
sont ceux
l'occupation de l'ensemble de notre
espace et notre territoire qui assure la
diversité de l'agriculture et qui prenne
en compte bien sur l'emploi je pense que
c'est important dans une période où vous
le savez tous aujourd'hui cette question
de l'emploi est au coeur des politiques
qui doivent être conduites merci
monsieur le ministre madame bourzai
merci monsieur le ministre de cette
réponse et je partage l'essentiel de vos
préoccupations qui sont aussi les nôtres
je voulais vous dire que j'étais il y a
peu de temps à nicosie à la réunion des
parlements sur justement l'avenir de la
pac et que votre proposition de
supprimer les premiers hectares a été
jugé enfin été acceptée on va dire
favorablement par le commissaire ciolos
à une question du germinal peiro donc je
pense que là nous avons une oreille
attentive est favorable et puis j'étais
également la semaine dernière au
colloque organisé la fnsea
voyez que on va dans toutes les réunions
sur l'emploi à clermont ferrand et je
peux vous dire que l'après les
préoccupations que j'exprimais tout à
l'heure et que vous avez reprises comme
des accords sont vraiment au coeur des
préoccupations des agriculteurs et des
éleveurs du massif central avec en
particulier
cette préoccupation des handicaps
naturels mais aussi d'avoir des
campagnes qui soit à la fois viables
économiquement et vivable socialement si
la parole est à monsieur dominique
watrin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues hier les sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
s'opposer au traité pour la stabilité la
coordination et la gouvernance de la
zone euro
aujourd'hui dans les négociations sur le
budget européen la france se heurtent de
plein fouet à l'austérité organisée par
ce pacte qu'elle a accepté comme vous le
savez monsieur le ministre la réforme de
la pac est largement hypothéquée par
l'accord sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel européen pour la période
2014 2020
dans ce contexte nous partageons vos
craintes sur l'avenir de cette politique
fondatrice de l'europe
crainte est d'ailleurs renforcée par le
virage très libérale de la réforme de la
politique agricole commune qu'ignore
temps les exigences de solidarité que
les exigences sociales et c'est sur
cette négation social que je voudrais
vos interrogé d'une part si les
instances européennes proposent une
conditionnalité des aides liées au
nombre d'emplois sur une exploitation la
conditionnalité sociale n'existe pas
comment lutter monsieur le ministre
contre les pratiques innommable de
société d'un terrible véritables
marchands d'hommes qui vante les
avantages de l' embauche de travailleurs
d'autres pays de l'union européenne
parce que exempté de cotisations
sociales
quelles propositions portera la france
pour mettre fin à ce dumping social
néfaste à l'ensemble du secteur
d'autre part nous sommes très inquiets
quant à la survie de l'aide alimentaire
qui risque d'être la première victime de
l'austérité de quoi parle-t-on de moins
de 500 millions d'euros pour permettre à
18 millions de personnes de manger une
fois tous les deux jours
alors qu'elles ont été alors qu'elles
ont mis 400 milliards d'euros pour
sécuriser les banques de plus le nouveau
fonds européen d'aidé aux plus démunis
sera cofinancé à hauteur de 15% par les
états il est à craindre que cela se
traduise encore par une baisse
significative des financements quel
engagement pouvez vous donc prendre pour
répondre aux associations et aux banques
alimentaires qui viennent en aide en
europe à plus de 18 millions de
personnes chaque année
la france va-t-elle agir en faveur d'un
maintien des dotations jusqu'à leur
attribuer merci mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre ce président ce
sénateur vous avez évoqué plusieurs
sujets vous avez pas d'abord parlé de la
question des traités et de l'austérité
vécu comme les conditions qui sont mises
à régler une partie d'une question qui
est posée pour beaucoup de pays qui est
la tête ce que deux choses l'une où yann
dette n'y en a pas si on considère qu'un
appât c'est vrai qu'il ya pas de raison
de la diminuer s'il ya une dette et
qu'il faut la rembourser il faut qu'on
en tienne compte quand même peut pas
faire comme si ça n'existait pas donc il
ya des efforts à faire
c'est ce que fait la france mais en même
temps on doit pouvoir soutenir
sens et on doit pouvoir mobiliser des
fonds pour la soutenir sur la réforme de
la pac et sur la pac
vous avez évoqué des sujets qui sont
connexes à la politicaillerie veulent ce
dont vous parlez avec le fait que des
travailleurs viennent exonérées de
cotisations ou même travailler dans des
pays aux conditions des pays d'origine
et non pas du pays d'accueil
c'est une directive sur le temps de
travail sur le travail qui sapait la
directive détachement mais qui autorise
comme ça des entreprises à pouvoir
utiliser et avoir recours à de la main
d'oeuvre qui est effectivement à des
conditions qui n'ont rien à voir avec
des conditions du pays d'accueil
véritable problème ça ne se pose pas sur
la politique est comme ça se pose de
manière globale sur la politique temps
de travail travail et en particulier
détachement c'est un vrai sujet de
l'harmonisation sociale à l'échelle
européenne
je suis convaincu comme vous qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à laisser penser qu'
on peut faire ce genre de choses au
niveau européen deuxième point
on a aussi avec des voisins des
divergences fondamentales dans
l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire
aujourd'hui en allemagne a pas de
convention collective comme vous le
savez les salaires minimum en allemagne
sont décidés par des conventions
collectives par branches ça existe dans
l'industrie mais ça n'existe pas dans
l'agro alimentaire l'agriculture
ce qui fait que là il ya un avantage
concurrentiel pour l'allemagne qui
évidemment pour nous et une concurrence
qui est difficile à pouvoir rattraper et
là c'est le sujet aussi de cette
question sociale à l'échelle européenne
qu'il faut poser j'espère que le débat
en allemagne sur smic eux aussi va
progresser c'est en tout cas le voeu que
l'on peut formuler quant au pead est la
position du gouvernement a été clair et
la mienne depuis le départ nous
soutenons le fait qu'il faut maintenir
une ligne budgétaire pour le pead est
parce qu il serait pas compréhensible
pour tous les citoyens européens qu'à
l'époque où 18 millions 10,9 millions
ont du mal à accéder alimentation qu'on
coupe c'est une budgétaire merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur watrin oui
monsieur le ministre je sais que nous
n'avons pas la même appréciation du
traité sur la stabilité la coordination
et la gouvernance mais je ce que je
retiens de votre propos c'est que nous
partageons les mêmes préoccupations sur
la nécessité de lutter contre
l'exploitation des travailleurs et les
fraudes aux règles liées au détachement
d
salariés et je crois qu'il est vraiment
important que l'ensemble des forces de
gauche portent ces exigences fortes sur
ce sujet qui dépasse d'ailleurs le
secteur agricole comme vous l'avez dit y
compris pourquoi pas en demandant une
renégociation de la directive européenne
si elle est mal faite en l'état en ce
qui concerne le programme européen
d'aidé aux plus démunis
la réduction de l'effort européen alors
que l'europe libérale est la grande
responsable de l'augmentation de la
pauvreté serait un coup porté à
l'exigence d'une europe des peuples
solidaires et bien nous n'accepterons
pas de recul ce recul alors que la
précarité fait d'année en année plus de
victimes
pour illustrer mon propos dans mon
département avec 3200 tonnes de
nourriture distribuées par an la banque
alimentaire est l'une des trois
principales associations frigo française
le secours populaire du pas-de-calais a
pris l'an dernier a pu l'an dernier
distribuer un million de repas dont ont
bénéficié quatre mille deux cents
familles soit 20000 personnes
la question est donc loin d'être à nu
anecdotique et je vous remercie de
l'avoir souligné vous aussi l'europe est
en phase peut-être d'affamés ces peuples
ce n'est pas exagéré de le dire il ya
donc urgence comme vous le vous y êtes
engagé obtenir des réponses et des
engagements concrets pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune diminution de dz pour l'aide
alimentaire net
merci la parole est à monsieur dominique
de legge pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
des centaines de producteurs laitiers
venus de plusieurs pays européens ont
convergé lundi vers le parlement
européen qui l'ont aspergé de l'est pour
y manifester contre la baisse des prix
en europe
en 2009 la production de l'air était
surabondante en australie en nouvelle
zélande
les poids lourds mondiaux cette
production or dans le même temps la
crise économique avait provoqué une
chute de la consommation mondiale d'eau
un effondrement des prix internationaux
qui avait provoqué une baisse de la
rémunération des éleveurs européens
cette année la situation est très
différente les prix mondiaux du lait
continue de se redresser alors qu'on
aurait pu penser qu'il se tracerait
puisqu'on est au plus fort de la
production en océanie et que la collecte
s'annonce encore très belle
en australie en nouvelle zélande mais
contrairement à 2009 la demande mondiale
reste très forte la chine importe la
russie est fortement à chevreuse tout
comme le moyen orient d'où la fermeté
persistante des prix mondiaux
paradoxalement les producteurs européens
ne profite pas de cette formidable
croissance de la consommation
ils pâtissent d'une part de la guerre
des prix entre les industriels et les
distributeurs
d'autre part ils sont affectés par les
prix du fourrage devenus exorbitants
avec la hausse du prix mondial des
céréales
cet handicap européen des aliments du
bétail les néo-zélandais ne l'ont pas
puisque les bêtes sont très largement
nourrie dans les pâturages et sans doute
le poids des charges et des normes est
il plus élevé chez nous qu'ailleurs nos
éleveurs sont découragés la collecte est
d'ailleurs en baisse cette année sur le
ministre tout à l'heure en réponse à
jean bizet vous avez indiqué je vous
cite la france va prendre des
initiatives
pouvez vous nous en dire un tout petit
peu plus s'agit-il d'initiative dans le
cadre de la négociation européenne en
cours en quoi l'évolution du budget du
ministère de l'agriculture pour 2013
préfigure ces initiatives et en quoi les
agriculteurs et singulièrement les
producteurs de lait vont ils être
concerné par le pacte de compétitivité
canon ce gouvernement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre ce président
le sénateur vous avez centre et votre
question sur la question du lait et en
faisant un tour d'horizon de la
situation mondiale en particulier on
passe en australie et nouvelle-zélande
il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le vrai
problème que nous avons en partie c'est
que l'indicateur de prix qui s'applique
même à la zone euro n'est pas lié à la
situation de la zone euro
mais vient effectivement de l'asie et en
particulier pacifique nouvelle zélande
australie ce qui est un vrai problème et
ce qui nécessitera d'ailleurs ça fait
partie des initiatives qu'on devra
prendre que l'europe soit capable elle
aussi en fonction de la situation de sa
demande la demande internationale de sa
demande au niveau continental bête
capable aussi de définir un niveau de
prix alors que là aujourd'hui
il s'impose non à l'europe
alors qu'il est défini ailleurs ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
il ya la question de la
contractualisation je voulais dit il
faut qu'on améliore le dispositif il
faut qu'on permette aux producteurs de
s'organiser
ça sera fait et ça sera chose faite
avant la fin de l'année mais pour
s'organiser il faut aussi qu'on leur
donne une lisibilité sur les prix c'est
la question des indicateurs de prix et
là il faut qu'on travaille sur ce sujet
pour permettre à nos producteurs à la
fois de s'organiser mais d'avoir des
garanties
je les dis de lissage des fluctuations
des prix et puis un dernier point ces
initiatives que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure j'ai envoyé un courrier au
commissaire européen qui a répandu
lumière suçons sa réponse aujourd'hui on
va prendre effectivement des initiatives
pour regarder à nouveau la question de
la sortie des quotas et de leurs
conséquences
aujourd'hui dans le système qu'on
connaît
si un pays se met à dépasser son niveau
de quotas et il peut y avoir des
sanctions qui seront prises demain
n'importe quel pays peut augmenter sa
production de 10 15% faire déstabiliser
le marché du lait tout entier à
l'échelle européenne sans qui rien qui
nous permettent aujourd'hui de venir
corriger les choses donc il ya un vrai
sujet et la france va poser ses
questions et elle a même proposé un
certain nombre de pistes sur lesquelles
on commence à réfléchir et sur lesquels
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir trouver un
compromis mais je sais que dans un
certain nombre de pays aujourd'hui la
situation des producteurs laitiers
elle est encore plus grave que ce que
nous pouvons avoir
chez nous en france et il faut qu'on
soit conscient que cet équilibre dans la
production laitière aujourd'hui il est à
repenser de manière globale avec en plus
une consommation de lait blanc inclut
les sur brick qui a baissé depuis
quelques années donc on a à penser la
transformation on a pensé les filières
on a repensé les système de
contractualisation c'est ce à quoi nous
nous engageons monsieur le ministre
monsieur de lège
merci monsieur ministres de cette
réponse je ne doute pas de votre
détermination de votre bonne foi je note
simplement dans la réponse
deux choses où je devrais dire je note
une chose et je regrette l'absence d'une
autre j'ai beaucoup entendu il faut nous
avons à penser nous avons à repenser
d'ici la fin de l'année mais en
attendant je reste vraiment sur ma faim
deuxièmement vous avez pas répondu à
deux dernières questions sur le fait que
le budget 2013 de l'agriculture
préfigurerait des initiatives que vous
entendez prendre et vous n'avez pas
répondu non plus à la question que je
vous ai posé sur l'application
l'agriculture du pacte de compétitivité
et langer un peu le sentiment que vous
en remettez beaucoup à l'europe et je
sais la part que leur obtient dans la
résolution de nos problèmes mais selon
le vieil adage
et toi le ciel t'aidera peut-être que si
vous aviez manifesté un tout petit peu
plus d'enthousiasmé pour nous expliquer
en quoi le gouvernement de notre pays
pourrait faire quelque chose j'aurais
été puisse rassurer pas votre réponse
vous remercie merci la parole est à
madame odette hervieux pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre
dans un contexte international
particulièrement tendu vous l'avez déjà
dit le dernier conseil européen consacré
aux perspectives financières de 2014
jusqu'à 2020 a malheureusement mis en
évidence des désaccords majeurs autour
de ce qui me semble moi être deux enjeux
particulièrement essentielle la place de
l'agriculture de notre modèle de
développement et l'évolution des
pratiques agricoles
le groupe de travail dont je faisais
partie les quais sont au nombre de
collègues ici présents en 2010 avait
souhaité notamment une pac plus juste
plus légitime aux yeux de nos
concitoyens
les propositions de monsieur le
commissaire dacia monsieur aulas
semblait aller dans ce sens en
conditionnant un tiers des subventions
directes à la bonne gestion des
ressources agricoles et en favorisant la
diversification des cultures le maintien
des pâturages et la mise en jachère
d'environ 7% destinée
à préserver l'état lui les haies
bocagères et la biodiversité
mais ce tiers de subventions pourraient
être directement menacés par la
diminution des aides à travers un
assouplissement des exigences
environnementales lors des débats
précédant au niveau européen
vous aviez proposé monsieur le ministre
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure une
dégressivité des aides aux premiers
hectares et une aide à l'élevage et vous
sembliez avoir été entendu le conseil
agriculture qui s'est réuni hier a
évoqué un système d'équivalence ou de
mesures alternatives et si nous sommes
attachés à la simplification des
procédures
nous devons quand même rester très
vigilants quant à leurs véritables
impacts sur l'environnement et examinés
avec la plus grande attention le système
de validation etc santé qui pourrait
sous le contrôle être sous le contrôle
de la commission européenne la remise en
cause probable des propositions de la
commission par la volonté de certains de
baisser drastiquement le budget de
l'europe et singulièrement celui de la
pac fait peser monsieur le ministre de
lourdes menaces sur l'avenir de notre
agriculture européenne et tout
particulièrement françaises alors même
si vous avez déjà répondu en grande
partie à ce que je viens d'évoquer
monsieur le ministre comment envisagez
vous l'avenir pour une pac plus
respectueuse des spécificités des
cultures de nos territoires et surtout
plus légitime au vu des enjeux
environnementaux
je vous remercie merci madame monsieur
le ministre ce président mais là bas ça
triche tu as odette herviaux je veux
juste te répondent oui le crédit d'impôt
s'applique à tout le monde
le crédit d'impôt bien un truc j'ai pas
répondu à cette question que ça
s'applique à tout le monde
quant à la question budgétaire j'ai cru
comprendre que hier vous n'aviez pas
voté le budget de magna global donc le
budget de l'agriculture en particulier
mais c'est pas sur le budget de
l'agriculture que on pourra régler les
problèmes spécifiques de la filière
laitière
ses global à l'échelle européenne et
puis c'est sur les règles qu'on va
mettre en place sur la
contractualisation sur la question posée
sur le verdissement
bien sûr qu'il ya risque aujourd'hui
mais certains pays serait tenté de dire
après tout besson le budget global de
l'europe besson budget de la politique
agricole
et comme il ya moins d'argent est bien
supprimant les
la partie verdissement ce qui est
d'ailleurs un peu contradictoire parce
que de toute façon cette partie
verdissement elle est intégrée au budget
ça ne changera rien le fait de le
baisser même si on dit après il ya + 30
% verdissement iliad a pu 19 12
ceux qui font ça de toute façon nos
comptes d'intention c'est de baisser les
objectifs du verdissement proposé par la
commission la france est le grand pays
qui défend ses objectifs de verdi san
quentin discussion qui a eu hier sur les
équivalences c'est vrai qu'il faut en
même temps qu'on trouve une manière
d'harmoniser sur ces questions de
l'environnement les pratiques des uns et
des autres et qui sont capables d'être
d'arriver à avoir et sur les objectifs
fixés par la commission diversification
des productions maintien des paires et
des prairies permanentes et surface
d'intérêt écologique une convergence au
sein du conseil différents pays et au
sein du parlement pour comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
cette politique environnementale elles
soient européennes et qu'on n'est pas 10
cases 20 politique environnementale qui
serait source là pour le coup là encore
de distorsion de concurrence
dernier point la france je les 10 et le
18 décembre durant un grand colloque va
prendre un leadership sur la question de
l'agroécologie pour redire ici au sénat
qu'écologie et économie
c'est pas antinomiques que quand je
parle d'économie chp est obligé de dire
que je ne suis je mets de côté
l'écologie que quand je veux parler
d'écologie
ça veut dire que j'oublie l'économie il
ya une combinaison des deux c'est
l'enjeu des vingt ans qui viennent et
pour notre pays qui est un grand pays
agricole c'est une source de leadership
c'est ce que je proposerai le 18
décembre merci monsieur le ministre
madame hervio
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je vous remercie pour votre
réponse
je tiens à saluer non seulement votre
engagement pugnace et votre volonté de
rendre compte de votre action au sénat
si bien que nos questions cribles
s'apparente presque à des questions
d'actualité et je connais votre
engagement depuis très longtemps sur
cette question de l'agroécologie
j'ajouterai tout simplement à vos propos
qu en effet nous sommes d'accord avec
vous ne pouvons pas accepter le
démantèlement programmé d'un dispositif
qui malgré tout depuis longtemps a
largement fait ses preuves tant sur le
en alimentaire et économique sociale et
territoriale nous devons par conséquent
tous ensemble nous opposer énergiquement
aux logiques libérales à courte vue qui
condamnerait à plus ou moins long terme
non seulement notre modèle agricole mais
surtout nos agriculteurs nous vous
soutiendrons donc très sincèrement
monsieur le ministre
dans tous les engagements que vous
prendrez dans ce sens là merci madame
dernière question celle de monsieur
yannick vaugrenard pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais limiter mon
intervention de produits emblématiques
pour avait une terre française le 20 et
le lait mais vous avez déjà répondu sur
le lez limite donc aux vins s'agissant
du vin nous inquiétons de la suppression
des droits de plantation qui avait été
décidée en 2008 lors de la réforme de
l'organisation commune du marché du vin
et nous suivons donc avec intérêt les
efforts entrepris par la france et
désormais 12 autres pays pour revenir
sur ses décisions de libéralisation nous
regrettons que la france ait laissé
passer cette réforme en 2008
en s'abstenant lors du vote préférant
l'option d'un rapport d'impact préalable
nous aurions pu constituer une minorité
de blocage à l'époque et cela aurait
évité beaucoup de tracas que nous
subissons aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'accorde à
dire en effet prévoir d'abolir les
droits de plantation et donc libéraliser
la plantation de vignes c'est en fait
renoncé un contrôle de l'offre
ceci aurait notamment pour conséquence
une extension des zones viticoles un
détournement de la notoriété des zones
d'appellation une baisse des prix
monsieur mini s'il reste désormais deux
pays me semble-t-il à convaincre
avez vous bon espoir d'y arriver ce
sujet at il été abordé au conseil
agricole je pense que oui pouvez-vous
nous en parler
cet après midi le directeur général de
l'agriculture à la commission européenne
vient enfin de reconnaître qu'une
régulation européenne de la production
viticole était nécessaire cette volte
face pour autant qu était attendu
donne-t-elle
selon vous l'engagement que les choses
ont véritablement changé
cependant la question de la régulation
des marchés agricoles se pose pour
l'ensemble des productions la volatilité
des cours des matières premières au
niveau mondial est inquiétante il est
difficile pour de nombreux agriculteurs
de se projeter dans l'avenir
par le passé on réguler les prix les
volumes produits les réformes
successives de la pac nous conduisent à
moins d'intervention sur les marchés
alors que les produits agricoles ne sont
pas des biens comme les autres
n'oublions jamais qu'il s'agit aussi de
notre sécurité alimentaire
nous comptons donc sur vous monsieur le
ministre pour sortir la pop et de la
politique agricole commune d'une
inquiétante dérive libérale je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre cette
présidence le sénateur cheria niveau à
l'art je vous avais concentrer votre
question est effectivement sur le
problème la problématique des des droits
de plantation sur le vin et vous savez
que depuis le début c'est à dire depuis
que je suis arrivé depuis six mois ça
fait partie des objets importants de
mobilisation du gouvernement
nous avons pu dès le mois de septembre
signé une plate forme commune avec
quatre grands pays producteurs la france
l'allemagne l'espagne et l'italie qui
demandait de manière très simple de
revenir sur la suppression des droits de
plantation prévu en fait en 2020
cette plate forme aujourd'hui est signée
alors d'après les derniers chiffres par
14 pays sur 15 pays producteurs il doit
nous rester je crois la tchéquie elle
est très claire
en plus elle porte sur l'ensemble de la
problématique à la fois sur les aoc sur
les i gp et sur les vins de table
parce qu'il s'agit pas non plus de
laisser penser qu'on pourrait faire tout
ce qu'on veut sur le mental
à condition de réguler les aoc ou l'isi
gp parce que je crois que l'expérience
d'ailleurs du bordelais a été
suffisamment explicite dans ce domaine
si vous laissez la production de vin se
banaliser c'est toute la production que
vous fragilisez et donc je pense que là
dessus c'est une vraie question là qui
consiste à dire cette idée qui a été
évoqué dans les eaux moment du bilan de
santé que l'europe allait conquérir tous
les marchés des nouveaux
pays consommateur avec des vingt deux
premières d'entrée de gamme et donc il
fallait libéraliser les droits de
plantation était une erreur stratégique
stratégie si on doit aller conquérir des
marchés il faut le faire dans l'ordre et
l'ordre dans la viticulture ces deux
matières des règles pour l'autorisation
des plantations
sinon on banalise un produit les
banalise en ce produit c'est toute la
filière qui demain risquera d'en payer
les conséquences donc nous sommes
vraiment tous attachés et moi j'ai été
surpris dès que j'ai commencé à discuter
de ce sujet de voir que les pays
producteurs ont réagi tous de la même
manière
maintenant l'adresse et à la commission
alors elle évolué j'ai vu le commissaire
européen moi-même normalement maintenant
on va aller quand même vers une
proposition qui doit faire en sorte que
l'europe revienne sur la décision qui
avait été prise 2007 2008 après on
pourra discuter des dates exactes mais
qui faisait courir le risque vous
l'avais dit dans les dettes d'une
libéralisation du marché du vin qui
aurait des conséquences dramatiques sur
cette production qui doit rester une
production qui ne peut pas être banal
c'est un produit spécifique qui a un
rapport suffisamment important de
terroir et la qualité pour que on
n'accepte pas de le voir se banaliser
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
vaugrenard oui merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre pour le volontarisme que
vous venez d'affiché concernant la
défense delà de la viticulture je pense
que ce volontarisme là sera
particulièrement utile lors de
négociations y compris au moment de
négociation d'un politique agricole
commune simplement d'un mot puisque
négociations sur les stratégies
financières vont avoir lieu très
rapidement sur les perspectives
financières 2014 2020 et à l'intérieur
de ses perspectives financières on
mesure le mesure bien le risque qu'il y
a deux des munitions des financements de
l'agriculture ce serait vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure une erreur
profonde de diminuer les crédits liés à
l'agriculture aujourd'hui dans une
période où les difficultés alimentaires
sur le continent d'une part sont
criantes et d'autre part sur l'ensemble
de notre planète
en conséquence et je voudrais me
permettre d'ajouter
et note un peu personnel à mon
intervention puisque je suis dernier
intervenir monsieur le ministre je pense
que chacun sur les bancs de notre
assemblée apprécié la manière dont vous
avez de répondre la qualité de
connaissance de vos dossiers et votre
détermination soutenir notre agriculture
non seulement au sein de nos territoires
mais également au sein de l'ensemble du
territoire européen en négociant avec
nos partenaires pied à pied et de
détermination vous avez affirmé je pense
satisfait tout le monde surtout des
bandes de cette assemblée quelle que
soit l'étiquette politique par ailleurs
je vous remercie
merci monsieur vaugrenard monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance sera repris à 16
heures pour l'examen de la suite du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2013
la séance est suspendue c'est la fin de
cette séance de questions cribles
consacrée à la réforme de la pac
si vous souhaitez revoir à cette séance
elle est disponible en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire c'est à 19h avec le
journal a présenté par michel grossiord
très bonne journée à tous